butterfly is a metaphor for crossing
borders the monarch butterfly freely
travels between Mexico the United States
and Canada so just like butterflies
cross because it's part of their DNA
migration has been part of our human
experiences at the beginning of the time
this piece in particular was an
opportunity for people to take their
photo in front of the butterfly as a way
to make a statement that we are citizens
of the world that the concept of nation
borders is an outdated concept and that
instead we're going to embrace the
humanity and defend the rights of
migrants and by standing in front of the
butterfly we are becoming butterflies
ourselves and in my work I attempt to
show the reasons why people cross people
cross because they want to be with their
families people cross because they love
their community and they
want to do what's best for their
children I'm the daughter of migrants
and were it not for my mother choosing
to leave her country I really would not
have had a future as an artist